où
[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro d' europe hebdo ici au
parlement européen à strasbourg plus que
cinq semaines avant les élections
européennes et nous continuons dans
cette édition notre tour d'europe cap
aujourd'hui sur l'italie pays fondateur
de l'union européenne qui fait beaucoup
parler de lui depuis près d'un an et
l'arrivée au pouvoir d'une coalition
contre nature composée du mouvement anti
système 5 étoiles et de la ligue
nous verrons dans notre reportage que
c'est le parti d'extrême droite qui
semble aujourd'hui surpasser son allié
débat à suivre dans cette émission mais
je vous propose d'abord de faire le tour
de l'actualité européenne des derniers
jours avec aurélie d'afas
[Musique]
les sociaux-démocrates reviennent au
pouvoir en finlande
vingt ans après sa dernière victoire la
formation de gauche est arrivé en tête
des élections législatives du weekend
dernier
elle dispose d'une très courte avance
sur le parti des vrais finlandais un
parti d'extrême droite eurosceptique le
chef de file des sociaux-démocrates va
désormais devoir composer une coalition
de gouvernement
en roumanie le parti de gauche au
pouvoir embarrasse les socialistes
européens alors que le pays est dans le
collimateur de l'union européenne pour
une réforme de la justice controversée
les alliés européens du parti
social-démocrate roumains ont décidé de
geler leurs relations avec cette
formation de gouvernement
le sort du psd au sein de la gauche
européenne devra figurer formellement à
l'ordre du jour d'une réunion au mois de
juin pour éviter une guerre commerciale
avec les etats-unis les européens
veulent négocier un accord avec
washington
les échanges devons porter sur les biens
industriels
la france a marqué une opposition de
principe à l'ouverture de ses
discussions avec un pays opposé à
l'accord de paris sur le climat mais les
27 autres états membres ont voté pour
l'ouverture des négociations
c'est donc désormais à washington
d'accepter cette proposition de paix
commercial les européens repousse la
date du brds excite réunis en sommet
extraordinaire les dirigeants des
vingt-sept ont accepté un nouveau report
uniquement pour laisser le temps
nécessaire à l'adoption de l'accord de
retrait avec une date butoir le 31
octobre 2019
un choix protecteur selon emmanuel
macron 7 buts et du 31 octobre nous
protège parce que soit ils ont un accord
et c'est très bien et nous pouvons à ce
moment-là discuter des relations futures
et poursuivre notre cheminement
soit ils décident eux mêmes de retirer
le break 6 soit de toute façon le no10
qui n'est pas notre préférence reste une
option
la balle est désormais dans le camp des
britanniques et pourront discuter j'ai
le plaisir d'accueillir sur ce plateau
de charles tannock bonjour bonjour vous
êtes britannique député européen
conservateur depuis 20 ans dans ce
parlement
alors avant de tenter d'analyser des
implications de ce nouveau report du
breakbeat j'aimerais que l'on revienne
rapidement sur cette actualité qui a
touché la france et sa capitale en début
de semaine cet incendie de la cathédrale
notre dame de paris un bijou d'histoire
et d'architecturé
j'imagine que l'émotion autour de cet
événement elle va bien au delà des
frontières de la france charles tannock
bien sûr
moi je suis au pays catholiques aussi
j'adore paris j'adore la france
c'est une tragédie un grand-père au mois
on la sauve et la plupart de la
cathédrale c'est un petit patrimoine
européen
c'est un patrimoine global même cette
année iconique pour tout le monde dans
le monde entier
c'est une grande tragédie et ma mère qui
habite à paris elle était elle était en
larmes tout ça comme beaucoup de
parisiens on va revenir maintenant sur
le brésil en est les implications de
cette de ce report avec est bien la
première conséquence directe ans et la
participation probable du royaume uni
aux élections européennes si l'accord
n'est pas votée d'ici le 23 mai alors
cette semaine
ici à strasbourg ça devait ça devait
être votre dernière semaine en tant que
député européen mais ce sera peut-être
pas le cas puisque vous avez l'intention
de vous présenter sur les listes de
votre parti comment vous abordez ce
scrutin particulier c'est un peu bizarre
bien sûr marché européen j'ai toujours
dit que le bridge pour moi c'est un
erreur mais le peuple a voté en 2016 il
ya
les frênes de madame elle a fait les
grands efforts et se force pour
respecter le voile du peuple en 2016 et
là est là où son accord de retraite et
n'a pas ou l'appui de l'opposition mais
aussi de certains députés de la droite
de mon parti on va voir maintenant si
elle a avec ces rapprochements qu'elle a
fait avec monsieur kobe pour trouver un
compromis peut-être dans l'union
douanière ça va fonctionner mais c'est
probable qu'on qu'il y aura des
élections européennes maintenant et moi
j'espère être candidat et de représenter
le relais toujours fait pendant 20 ans
et faire tout le mieux pour le citoyen
qui votent pour moi les britanniques
j'imagine en effet ont lieu presque
trois ans après le référendum comment
les britanniques abordent ce scrutin
vous conseiller
c'est intéressant héros ici l'on fait
des sondages et la majorité où ils sont
favorables aux hommes différents à
l'élection européen il ya 40% qui sont
fâchés qu'il y aura des élections est le
problème c'est que il y a les partis de
droite extrême droite qui volent sorti
il ya deux partir lorsque ptic
maintenant à leur avis les élections
sont une espèce de deuxième référendum
mais c'est pas comme ça parce que c'est
pas les eurodéputés qui peuvent décider
la sortie résultat des négociations
c'est ça c'est dans les mains de pas
l'amour nationale des députés nationaux
par les eurodéputés
alors justement ce compromis enfin ce
report pardon c'est un conte premier
risqué pour les européens puisque les
britanniques vont pouvoir peser sur le
scrutin européen certains partisans du
président ont déjà annoncé la couleur
on écoute si nous sommes obligés de
rester dans l'union nous devrions
devenir le membre le plus difficile
possible parce que je ne pense pas que
l'union européenne et son jargon s'est
comporté envers vous avec une sincère
volonté de coopérer je ne pense pas qu
une coopération sincère puisse inclure
une volonté de casser l'unité d'un état
membre lorsqu'il quitte l'union
européenne alors les européens auraient
souhaité tourner la page du break site
avant les européennes mais le dossier
risque d'interférer
dans la campagne dont ces élections mais
dans le travail même du futur parlement
jake brice mort guinée ne représente pas
la position officielle ni du
gouvernement ni du parti conservateur
il est chef d'une faction de droite
eurosceptique dans mon parti il est très
important dans cet aspect-là
mais ils ne parlent pas officiellement
pour le gouvernement et la coopération
sincère existera encore la plupart des
eurodéputés élus ici si nous sommes réel
où nous respecterons le parlement
européen et les traiter tout ça et moi
je serai ici si je suis réélu pour
représenter les intérêts de mon pays pas
pour détruire le projet européen c'est
ça a vraiment c'est comme le commentaire
fait pourrissement vraiment à mon avis
c'est très négatif était très destructif
au dernier conseil européen on a vu se
dessiner d'importantes lignes de
fracture entre les états membres
il y avait d'un côté donc l'allemagne
une quinzaine de pays qui souhaitait un
report le plus long possible et puis il
y avait de l'autre la france qui
souhaitait au contraire une extension la
plus courte possible alors les européens
étaient restés plutôt unis dans ce
dossier jusqu'à présent mais là le
dossier du breakbeat semble les diviser
il savait jusqu'au couple
franco-allemand est coté les sommets
sont toujours un compromis à la fin
entre l'imposition des allemands des
français des italiens etc
alors on a fini avec la date d'octobre
la fin d'octobre 31 octobre
c'est aussi possible il faudra avoir une
autre fondation je ne sais pas parce que
il à la question de non seulement
d'avoir son accord de retraite
appuyé par le gouvernement britannique
il ya aussi beaucoup de deux militants
maintenant dans le parlement national
pour surtout dans le parti socialiste
travailliste qui veulent une deuxième
réfrène de tout ça a besoin du temps et
peut-être aussi des élections anticipées
ont vraiment on ne sait pas comment
savoir finir au-delà des conséquences
indirectes convient d'évoquer beaucoup
s'interrogent sur l'utilité d'un tel
report la question c'est de savoir si le
président va vraiment avoir lieu écoutez
je ne sais pas sincèrement je ne suis
pas faire voyons le pluton qui passe le
plus faire devient le monde ah ça c'est
sûr parce qu'il y ait des jeunes qui
peut voter maintenant qu'ils sont plus
européistes
c'est intéressant de lebrac site aaa le
résultat que les britanniques
connaissent beaucoup mieux maintenant
comment ça fonctionne et rené d'une
européens qui avons équipé et crest près
pendant la campagne
tous les européens de tous les pays même
les pays avec les partis de droite
populiste a solis comme la france
l'italie sa vie ni les peines et ses
trains
tous ces pays là il ne parle plus de
l'idée de sortir et on écoute pas
tellement l'acceptation de france et
italie le break c'est un espèce de
vaccins contre tout ça
donald tous cas le président du conseil
européen on n'a jamais caché être
favorable à un maintien du royaume uni
dans l'union européenne une révocation
de l'article 50 une annulation du
président ça serait possible
6 millions de personnes ont signé
une pétition pour demander la révocation
de l'article 50 dont tu as pour moi
était a été en gros on est artiste
il a un vrai européen il respecte le
rôle joué par le royaume uni dont le
projet européen
c'est vrai que le royaume uni a toujours
eu une espèce de statut un peu différent
des autres on ne fait pas partie de
l'euro on ne fait pas partie de schengen
de la politique d'asile et d'immigration
et tout ça est à mon avis la sortie du
royaume uni total surtout avec un accord
un break c'est très dur va affaiblir le
royaume uni économiquement et
politiquement
et en terme de sécurité et en même temps
affaiblir les 27 qui reste sans nous
alors restez dans l'hymne européen
à mon avis ce serait préférable mais
pour faire ça il faudra à mon avis avoir
merci beaucoup de chance d'avoir été
notre invité aujourd'hui comme promis
nous prenons maintenant la direction de
l'italie où les européennes vont avoir
valeur de test pour la coalition
populiste au pouvoir depuis un an un
pays d'un peu plus de 60 millions
d'habitants dont le poids économique
représente 11 22% du pib de l'union
européenne l'italie est un membre
fondateur et envoie au parlement 73
eurodéputés à sa tête un président de la
république au pouvoir a limité sérgio
matar est là et un président du conseil
plutôt effacé guiseppe compté car dans
la péninsule
les véritables tenants du pouvoir sont
les deux vice-présidents du conseil
luigi di maio issu du mouvement 5
étoiles et surtout matteo salvini de la
ligue
les deux formations sortie victorieuse
des urnes lors des législatives
aujourd'hui c'est le parti d'extrême
droite qui caracole en tête des sondages
l'italie al'approche du scrutin européen
c'est un reportage signé ses cibles
siksou
[Musique]
il ya cinq ans dario tambour anneaux a
rangé sa blouse de dentiste désigné via
internet comme candidat par les
militants du mouvement 5 étoiles un
mouvement anti système
il a été élu député européen oui ça
c'est la homepage de rousseau c'est là
que je me log avec mon profil en profil
je vais arriver en 2014 avec une
réputation qui ne correspondaient pas à
la réalité
il disait que l'on était incompétent
avec une attitude populiste et
destructrice a démontré en travaillant
dans les commissions et en suivant
presque tous les textes de loi dès le
départ que cette image qu'on nous avait
collé ne correspondaient pas à la
réalité et ceci a été ensuite cesse le
26 mai prochain il sera plus difficile
pour lui de se faire une place au
parlement européen
les intentions de vote pour son
mouvement les 5 étoiles au pouvoir en
italie depuis un an ses frites dans les
sondages mais dario tambour anneaux a du
mal à le reconnaître en date visant
l'achat et sondages ne sont pas fiables
parce que ces dernières années c'est
comme si les algorithmes ne réussissait
pas à avoir une perception de la réalité
de l'électorat de l'électorat
[Musique]
pour ce politologue les tendances sont
claires la ligue
l'autre parti d'extrême droite du
gouvernement qui a obtenu 17 % aux
dernières législatives il y a un an
surpasse désormais son allié le
mouvement 5 étoiles quatre mois après
les élections il avait 30 ans poussant
et des ça ils ont gagné gagner gagner
gagner maintenant sa part est racing 36
% l'homme fort salvini
il y a une tradition en italie qu'il y à
beaucoup d électeurs qui prend ses
décisions dans les derniers 48 ou même
24 heures l'histoire nous dit que les
électeurs qui prendre ses décisions dans
les derniers moments
ils votent pour la plage les proposer
fort matteo salvini dario crie pas le
connais bien il a été son attaché
parlementaire à bruxelles si ce jeune
député italien eu lieu en mars dernier a
encore du mal à se faire un nom
[Musique]
il n'a pas d'inquiétude pour son parti
très populaire grâce à son mentor le
ministre de l'intérieur et sa politique
anti migrants là l'idée a mise désormais
sur les thématiques économiques
elle pourrait rafler un tiers des sièges
italien au parlement européen le 26 mai
prochain
il ya cinq ans on faisait 4 % en ce
moment la ligue est à 35 % en cinq ans
on a complètement changé la physionomie
politique en italie et on se prépare à
le faire en europe possible en devenant
le parti le plus puissant n'aura pas
qu'on mette pas ils vont pas devenir la
première force politique de l'union
c'est désormais l'objectif de matteo
salvini initialement hostile à l'europe
l'homme fort de l'italie a changé de
stratégie ils comptent
à l'issue de ces élections créer un
groupe des partis souverainistes qui
pourrait peser sur les décisions de
bruxelles
il va ainsi dans le sens des italiens
attachée à l'europe qui dans leur
majorité iront voter en mai ça lui a
manqué j'espère que tout le monde va
aller voter parce que l'europe c'est une
grande conquête on doit la garder mais
j'espère comme à chaque fois que l'on
défende les intérêts de l'italie de
notre pays j'attends que les choses
changent là et que la gauche puisse être
ce qu'elles étaient avant
la gauche italienne marginalisés depuis
sa débâcle aux législatives il ya un an
compte sur ce scrutin européen pour
renaître de ses cendres
le parti démocrate a élu son nouveau
chef
nicola zingaretti lit armoire est
mobilisé contre toute attente 1 million
600 mille votants pour ces primaires
tout de suite après cette élection il y
a eu dans les sondages une petite
croissance de la gauche c'est à dire
c'est comme si les gens ont des gauchers
attendez on signale de vie non un verset
à la personne derrière lui
tout sauf réaliste à milan juste pour
l'instant l'impression est que mouvement
5 étoiles et ligue du nord ils font le
gouvernement et l'opposition à eux mêmes
dans le même temps et ça c'est pas
bientôt la démocratie ce n'est pas bien
bien sûr pour la gauche qui n'a pas d'
espace où chercher à montrer sa voix
pour les italiens l'enjeu de ces
européennes serait d'éviter que la
coalition entre la ligue et le mouvement
5 étoiles déjà fissuré n'arrive au point
de rupture et provoque une crise interne
et de nouvelles élections législatives
[Musique]
vous avez rejoint la république en
marche il ya un an à vos côtés
aujourd'hui alberto romagnoli bonjour
vous êtes le spécialiste des affaires
européennes pour la rai la télévision
publique italienne
première question pour vous alberto
romagnoli on a vu dans ce reportage dans
cette tendance qui semble s'inverser
avec le parti de matteo salvini qui
pourrait remporter plus du tiers des
sièges italien dans le futur parlement
européen comment vous l'expliquez vous
savez les italiennes zone de problème
l'économie et l'immigration
et dans les deux domaines ils pensent
que c'est la faute de l'europe sur
l'économie parce qu'il ya des règles
européennes et qui sont excellents cela
pour l'allemagne on dit que l on a créé
l'hérault la façon allemande et c'est
vrai que les niveaux de vie des
italiennes
ces pillards après 20 ans d'euros et
l'immigration nous on était là c'est
seul à l'europe
et ça il ya des autres chefs des
gouvernements qui dit et c'est vrai on a
fait quelque part que c'est de passer
pour les italiennes donc d'une
solidarité vis-à-vis des titres et des
italiens il ya aussi le mouvement 5
étoiles qui a peut-être du mal à trouver
sa place face à matteo salvini qui est
extrêmement médiatique
oui c'est le débat de ces heurts on a
peut-être en guerre en libye cette vigne
il dit il ya des centaines de milliers
d'émigrants qui vont arriver en italie
et les ports d'alien ils vont rester
fermés et 5 étoiles dit excuse moi s'il
ya des gens qui vont fuir la guerre
mondiale en moins les aider il ya une
grosse différence de vues en effet sur
le sujet de l'immigration qui pourrait
rester de fracturer cette coalition en
tout cas à matteo salvini à emmanuel
macron qui se sont désignés mutuellement
comme principal adversaire de notre en
europe est ce que c'est aussi le moyen
gilles pargneaux d'éviter le clivage
traditionnel droite gauche selon vous ce
qui me concerne
l'occasion de ces élections européennes
du 26 mai le combat que nous devons
avoir c'est démontrer que l'europe c'est
la solution et non pas le problème comme
vous venez de l'indiquer donc il y à la
nécessité d'expliquer d'expliquer que
par exemple la problématique
grandissante en matière économique
les difficultés économiques que l'italie
peut avoir c'est parce que nous aurons
une nouvelle politique industrielle
européenne que nous pourront
effectivement résoudre des problèmes
économiques
c'est parce que nous pourrons à
l'échelle de l'europe développer une
politique migratoire notamment comme
nous le proposons avec les pays du sud
du pourtour de la méditerranée européen
pour qu'on ait une union de solidarité
sur la migration etc un puck ensuite
donc on puisse avoir une répartition
entre ces pays
mais sur ces dossiers il ya aussi ce
positionnement contre les nationalistes
évidemment donc à partir du moment où
ceux qui sont anti européens comme les
nationalistes veulent moins d'europe
nous devons donc ainsi expliqué aux
italiens aux français et à d'autres
membres de l'union européenne que la
solution c'est pas moins d'europe c'est
pas de se recroqueviller derrière ses
frontières au contraire nous y
trouverons des solutions parce que nous
aurons une politique européenne ait
baissé parce que nous aurons la
possibilité de développer des politiques
de migration solidaire avec cette union
de solidarité que nous proposons que
nous arriverons à trouver cette
solidarité se partage de la politique
migratoire
alors on va justement écouter cette
journaliste sur le thème de
l'immigration en italie dans la campagne
les thèmes économiques c'est peut être
le plus important suivi du thème de
une émigration c'est l'italie a beaucoup
payé en termes de devoir gérer les
migrations qui arrivent d'afrique est
très souvent on a dit on ne m'en a pas
eu l'europe de notre côté et donc ça
c'est en deuxième thème dans ce moment
on en parle un peu moins que dans le
mois passé mais je suis sûr que ça va
revenir bientôt
voilà donc l'immigration va beaucoup ont
parlé on en a beaucoup parlé dans ce
débat mais matteo salvini semble changer
un peu stratégie recentrer son discours
finalement sur l'économie alberto
romagnoli oui évidemment solvin il
commet vous avez montré dans les sujets
va devenir la première force politique
européenne et l'idée c'est de faire des
alliances avec des autres pays pour
changer les règles européennes
après on sait que c'est toujours très
difficile
ma c'est vrai qu'il ya un problème sur
les règles après la construction de
l'est de l'euro c'est pas complet et ça
fait des années des années non ça et
alors pas seulement les italiennes j'ai
passé sans peur de l'espoir que l'europe
a changé leur vie dans les débats en
france aussi sur ça il faut faire
comprendre également à l'occasion de ces
élections européennes que
il faut effectivement changer l'europe
il faut qu'on ait plus d'équité fiscale
car on doit éviter à l'intérieur même de
la zone euro des inégalités fiscales
fiscales telles que nous pouvons les
constater et les connaître et nous
devons aussi avoir une gouvernance
économique de la zone euro qui
permettent de ne pas avoir une seulement
qu'une politique financière une monnaie
unique comme vous le rappelez fort
justement à l'instant le problème c'est
les gros ni terre et va dépenser plus
pour lancer les investissements
oui il dit nous ne pouvons pas relancer
l'investissement parce que bruxelles dit
toujours non ça c'est voilà et donc nous
nous proposons dans le cadre de cette de
ce combat contre des conservateurs
contre les libéraux la création d'un
fonds d'ajustement sur la mondialisation
doté d'un milliard d'euros pour pouvoir
faire ces investissements industriels
stratégiques à l'échelle de l'europe où
il ya un sujet économique qui semble
diviser la coalition c'est l'adhésion
récente de l'italie aux fameuses routes
de la soie
ce grand projet d'infrastructure chinois
écoutez notre objectif avec cet accord
est de commencer à rééquilibrer une
disproportion qui fait qu'il y attend de
l'iemed in china qui vient en italie et
trop peu de made in italy qui va en
chine la chine alors le mouvement cinq
étoiles a salué cet accord matteo
salvini a plutôt pris ses distances mais
il ya surtout les partenaires européens
de l'italie qui s'inquiètent de ce
projet gilles pargneaux mais quand on
entend des maillots s'exprimer comme il
vient de le faire
c'est exactement ce qu'a dit le
président macron récemment au président
chinois disant nous souhaitons non pas
seulement qui est des investissements
chinois en europe ou en france
mais nous souhaitons que nos
investisseurs nos entreprises puissent
aussi investir le marché chinois
il faut qu'on rééquilibre et la
difficulté de l'italie c'est qu'ils ont
fait cavalier seul dans cet accord
qu'ils ont signé il ya quelques mois
maintenant avec la chine
la chine a déjà investi dans le port du
pirée en grèce aussi un réseau est nommé
l'épisode dans le cas de la route de la
soie il ya des investisseurs chinois qui
sont présents partout en europe
là on est sur un accord que l'italie a
voulu développer tout seul tout seul
et alors que je couds que je pense que
nous avons intérêt à faire en sorte que
ce soit à l'échelle de l'union
européenne que nous puissions avoir
c'est sa copine avis si elle vise un
investissement tant que sur le
territoire européen que vers la chine
paris affirme au contraire des 300
avions d'airbus acheter des produits en
france ça c'est pas la france qui va
cavalière seule sais c'est quoi un
business française en business européen
n'est pas la propriété de la france où
ce n'est que c'est un projet européen
que nous devons avoir en tête et c'est
aussi pour ça
rappelons nous que airbus est aussi
puissant dans le monde parce que nous
avons réussi alors c'était pas à
l'échelle de l'ensemble de l'union
européenne mais dans le cas d'une
coopération avec un autre état membre de
l'union européenne
là il ya un autre sujet d'inquiétude sur
l'économie italienne c'est une
information qui est passée un peu
inaperçue la semaine dernière avec le
brésil mais l'italie s'est accordé sur
un nouveau projet de budget avec des
prévisions de croissance revues à la
baisse et donc un déficit estimé à 2 4 %
c'est exactement le chiffre qui avaient
été jugées inacceptables par bruxelles à
l'automne dernier alberto romaine oui
c'est évident qu'ils à notre bataille
entre rome et bruxelles après les
élections européennes
c'est très évident qu est
également été repensée jouer cette
bataille avec un grand art mais deux
erreurs des potées pour être avec des
amis dans les pays de l'est dans des
amis même en allemagne
et même en france avec madame le pen 30%
rappeler toujours que un endettement
excessif
une nuit à la croissance économique et
nuit au développement donc il faut
effectivement veillée c'est ce que fait
je pense avec justesse pierre moscovici
le commissaire européen en ce domaine
pour permettre est-ce que nos états
membres n'est pas un endettement
excessif
on a trouvé un accord ces derniers mois
avec ce nouveau gouvernement italien et
la commission européenne
donc moi j'ai bon espoir que nous
pourrons après les élections européennes
continuer le dialogue pour faire en
sorte qu'on puisse trouver ce point
d'équilibré entre un endettement qui ne
doit pas être exhaustif et ce dialogue
sera pas neuve qui doit permettre à
chacun de pouvoir développer son
industrie où son économie pour plus de
croissance
ce dialogue qui peut se faire avec la
ligne mais évidemment qu'il s'est fait
avec le gouvernement italien
que ce soit
les cinq étoiles où la ligue puisque le
gouvernement est constitué de ces deux
formations en tout cas pour revenir à la
campagne
en italie la campagne pour les
européennes le parti démocrate a mis le
cap le cap à gauche avec l'élection à sa
tête de nicola zingaretti un qui était
le plus à gauche des candidats dans ces
primaires est ce que vous pensez que le
parti démocrate avec ce nouveau
président va être plus audible vis-à-vis
de cette coalition en italie et c'est
très difficile parce qu est comme dire
de la plupart des italiennes le gect
l'expérience des gouvernements de gauche
de cinq dernières années c'est-à-dire
n'a pas envie de notre ère et initiale a
regretté doit démontrer que c'est un peu
différent beaucoup plus différent des
n'est rien si c'est vrai aussi que
encore les regards de leurs l'europe
c'est un défi c'est à dire montrer que
l'europe ça marche sur l'immigration et
sur l'économie
et comme je disais ça prend du temps
pour ce projet et les italiennes et the
problem jour par jour ça c'est je dirais
qu'il ya montré différents entre
bruxelles et rome l'italie au défi des
dossiers migratoires et économique pour
ces élections européennes merci à tous
les deux d'avoir été nos invités
aujourd'hui merci à vous de nous avoir
suivis vous pouvez retrouver cette
émission en replay sur nos différents
sites lcpan public sénat et rtbf.be à
bientôt pour un nouveau numéro d' europe
hebdo
[Musique]